اسطنبول من اكثر المدن اكتظاظا في العالم
هي المدينه الخامسه عشره في ترتيب المدن
المكتظه والوجهه السياحيه
الرائده وخاصه في المناطق السياحيه مثل
شارع الاستقلال ومن طاقه تقسيم ناشطون على
مواقع التواصل نشروا فيديوهات تظهر لحظه
وقوع الانفجار في الاستقلال في منطقه
تقسيم
صور مرعبه وقاسيه جدا على كل حال اسطنبول
هي
مدينه كبيره في شمال تركيا تنقسم الى
قسمين القسم الاسيوي والقسم الاوروبي ها
هو ميدان تقسيم يقع في القسم الاوروبي
شارع الاستقلال هذا هو وشارع تجاري
المكان الذي حصل في الانفجار وهو مقصد
سياحي مهم في البلاد الحادث طبعا اثاره
حاره من الصدمه والحزم على منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي فغرد خالد المطيري يقول الله
يستر انفجار في تقسيم اسطنبول ومعظم اللي
بالمنطقه سياح هذه تغريده من مصطفى عماد
مصطفى يقول تقسيم الجميله ليش الاماكن
المزروعه بالفرح والموسيقى والحب يصير
بهائيه
غسان ياسين يقول غسان اختيار يوم الاحد
لتنفيذ هذا الهجوم من الهدف منه ايقاع
اكبر عدد من الضحايا لان الشارع بالاتراك
والسياح سلامتك يا اسطنبول هشام البوغانمي
يقول اللهم بردنه وسلاما على تركيا تركيا
ماضيا نحو الفين و 2023
بالنسبه لحصيله الضحايا فوالي اسطنبول علي
يرغايه قال اربعه قتلى 38 جريحا جراء
الانفجار الذي وقع في شارع الاستقلال في
منطقه تقسيم بمركز المدينه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]